hey guys how's it goin so I'm sure
you've seen the monorover the gliders
that sure you can hear jb chewing with
his mouth full oh holy moly you're so
loud alright let's unbox this thing okay
so the monorover glider scooter is
segway without a hand holder what the
hell are they call
it's a hunger cube this mark you I'll
put a link in the description we're not
getting shoes huh weekend shoes weekend
shoes for you somebody actually calls it
I'm just sorry weekend shoes shoes like
somebody's already been in here pretty
cool that was great
you won't believe it it's really cool
weekend shoes wait where's the button
they're blue I'm very severely upset
it's really upset how do i how do i
change the LED lights no I do I do
can you hurry it up at first you know
there's three visits right party Jenna's
maths I haven't done this in a while
just get on it just go for it yeah go
ahead
holy moly okay we're good let me just
get might get my bearings
this feels a lot this still like the
white one
these are violent yeah no oh my god
who's this Bob you gotta throw it away
mommy we can just compare it should I
get on my - crap oh hi mine doesn't
sound like that
that's yours making the noises yeah
there's a negative sound I waited so
long for this
well it works yeah it's not fast can you
go do the column to stop let me do it
can sounds like you're a race it's an
actual shots I'm sure it's not it
matches your socks too
it's literally a racecar whole squad on
that real stuff without colors there's
make a triangle to words you should just
see okay all right you're single right
see you they feel like I'm gonna die
it's like like playing call of duty on a
huge TV and then going to us and then
going to a monitor but there's this is a
TV there's lack if there actually is
lack his response Jenna you need to hop
on this and see like one millisecond 205
no this is like a 10 don't you're gonna
wipe out I would be faster that's it I
think I'm actually gonna keep this one
because what I like about it is it makes
it a little bit easier for new people
that are using it and since you know I'm
clearly an expert monorover hover over I
can't say who will hover hover hover
board the light or whatever it's called
what is this what do we decide on
calling this two girls two girls two
guys three our words okay what many boys
two girls
no one helped me - two boys two girls
- I wanna do things are like young adult
one young male though one young male
adult oh my god you
wonderful mail look at that look at that
one puppy and you have a puppy now two
girls two boys one puppy
so did you many mad did a good job last
night sleeping how did you do a good job
sleeping last night sort of he only woke
me up two times